indeed a big score linear
congratulations you must feel really
good about today's results
yeah thank you yeah it's great to to
start like this um i didn't know really
what to expect because
i didn't play for such a long time i
mean i played a couple of games in the
world cup but i think the last time that
i played over the award was like almost
i mean that feels like i don't know an
eternity but like almost two years ago
uh but it really went well so yeah i'm
happy hikaru was saying he doesn't think
it makes a difference he thinks online
at the table
as long as you're looking at chess all
the time you should be fine what was
your formula for for getting in such
fine form for this day no i always say
that i i somehow i enjoy much more
playing uh face to face and maybe it was
the way i was used to plays and so i
mean i didn't
grow up in the online
generation so much so
i was used to play just normal over the
world since my childhood so
i always feel more more comfortable also
it's i don't know easier to kind of
concentrate and feel that you are in the
tournament and so on so i was really
looking forward to to
to play uh chess face to face again and
you know
i hope it uh keeps going
you really cleaned up with the white
pieces today i mean it just looked
almost effortless in some way oh what
was
your white preparation what made made it
so excellent yeah well i was playing
italian but i think in the first game i
was a bit lucky probably because uh i
mean
usually you don't win games like this i
basically did nothing i was putting my
business more or less at least that's
how
i felt that i was bringing my key in and
just taking some small space and all of
a sudden i was close to winning so
i guess that one was
uh i was a bit lucky there maybe he made
some some uh mistake in a really
defensible position
but this but the the last game was of
course a bit more uh
complicated i mean i
just got a really nice position uh from
the opening but i had so many options
that what usually happens i spent too
much time and then i was uh
down to one minute uh still winning but
of course then
i had some practical problems but yeah i
i managed at the end
earlier i saw you having lunch with your
wife and son usually people try to get
the family away
but you had the family right before you
came to sit down and play you're not
worried at all about that being a
distraction and it seemed to work out
quite well for you yeah it's uh
well uh it's also important to kind of
get out of the preparation and the
tournament uh
attention so i thought that it might
might be good and also my son is
starting school soon so i i thought this
might be
his
last vacation weekend i thought we could
spend some time together so
that's a plan
that's fantastic seeing you know parents
we saw allison felix and the olympics do
well with her daughter around it's
always nice to have that contact with
your kids congratulations and good luck
in the rest of your games thank you
lanier
just one quick question i know you're a
great player you're a veteran in these
tournaments and you know how tough it is
to win a game and we just witnessed
around where there was five decisive
games
how does that happen i mean just does
everybody go crazy at the same time well
in in rapids and blitz it's uh
i think you you will see a lot of more
decisive games because more mistakes and
little time so anything can happen so i
guess it has to do with that maybe in
the classical game we will see more
solid play excellent thank you good luck
for the rest of it thank you